I decided to take my wife's last name
and it was the best decision I've ever
made
hi my name is Andy Golder you might know
me as that guy on BuzzFeed who likes
game thrones way too much but two years
ago my name wasn't Andy Golder it was
Andy new and wander I got married in
2016 and I decided to take my wife's
last name we had a lot of reasons for
this decision including but not limited
to wanting to have the same last name
wanting my wife to keep the name that
she had started her career with and me
wanting to get rid of the 14 letter
monstrosity that I had lived most of my
life with after much deliberation and a
detailed pro/con list we decided that
the best idea was for me to become a
Golder here's what I've learned in the
first two years of having a shiny new
last name number one some people do not
know how to respond the first person we
told about the decision for me to take
my wife's last name was actually a
server at a restaurant we were
celebrating our engagement and when she
took my credit card she made a joke
about how my wife must really not be
looking forward to taking my crazy last
name when we told her that I was
actually taking my wife's last name
she laughed thinking that we were like
joking about it then she like kind of
looked confused for a moment and then
she just sort of ran away and ran the
card number two people seem to think of
it as a last resort
people always say things like oh I have
friends who just combined their last
names together have you guys ever
thought of doing that but to me why does
a completely new made-up name you know
make more sense than one that already
has a history and current familial ties
and things like that
how was both of us losing our last names
preferable to a man taking his wife's
last name also new and gold sounds kind
of dumb and gold Schwann dur sounds like
liqueur with gold flakes in it that i
may or may not have thrown up in college
and there is literally not enough time
in the world for me to introduce myself
as andy new and wander colder if we
hyphenated it number three changing your
name is actually really hard you have to
go to both the Social Security office
and the DMV which are pretty much the
two worst places in the world and then
even after you've done that part in your
name is legally changed then you have to
change your last name on everything
you've ever signed up for in the history
of the internet a lot of places require
a certified copy of your marriage
certificate which costs money and takes
time so it's a huge pain to this day I
still haven't gotten around to changing
my paypal number for women usually love
the idea
my wife's group text with her
bridesmaids had like a lot of heart
emojis and stuff in it
my mom had always kept her birth name so
she was of course in approval a female
friend of mine even gave me her
incredibly helpful checklist of things
to do after she took her husband's last
name but of course I still freaked out a
bunch of stuff number five some men are
definitely weirded out by it generally
men were supportive as well but one of
my friends when I pressed him about it
he admitted that he and I quote would
never
when my wife informed her uncle of the
change he asked if that was even legal
number six the system really isn't set
up for men it was ultimately just as
easy for me to get my name changed as it
would be for a woman but there are these
little things along the way that kind of
remind you how rare what you're doing
really is for example the most popular
name change system is called miss now
mrs. calm this and I'm not mad and I'm
sure it's a great service but it was
just kind of funny to me you don't
really realize how automatic the
thinking is around name changing until
you actually do it
we hired a photobooth company for our
wedding like everybody else in the last
ten years and they provided us with this
really nice scrapbook of everybody's
photobooth photos at the end and on one
of the pages they had written the phrase
he stole my heart so I stole his last
name of course I don't fault the owners
they were wonderful but it just kind of
shows how automatic the thinking is
number seven I feel like I have to
explain myself a lot every time I'm
talking to some poor customer service
person and I
and have to tell them that I changed my
name a simple I got married never seems
to suffice instead it turns into me
going on this long thing like oh I got
married and I had this really long last
name and you know I had a blah blah blah
and it just turns into this whole thing
number 8 a lot of people probably just
assumed that my wife changed her last
name my wife realized this shortly after
we made the change and she said you know
people are probably just gonna think
that you were always a Golder and then I
took your last name she's probably right
in a 2015 study over 70% of women who
married men took their husband's last
name about 20% chose to keep their own
last name the other 10% chose a third
option which means anything from
combining the last name to even taking
their husband's last name but using
their own last name professionally more
recently though 2017 UK studies showed
that one in ten recently married British
men decided to take their wife's last
name number nine it was all totally
worth it having my wife's last name a
name that we both loved was worth all of
the many many forms that I filled out so
whether you're keeping your own name
combining it changing it to something
else just do your thing it'll be the
perfect choice for you well I wrote an
article for BuzzFeed about taking my
wife's last name and the whole process
of it and the response I got was fairly
mixed a lot of the response was really
positive I got a lot of tweets from
people saying that they had also taken
their wife's last name some of the
responses have been negative - for sure
you know I think a lot of people have a
really traditional idea of this and
that's probably not going to go away
it's a little sad sometimes when people
are just really fundamentally opposed to
this because I don't see why it's such a
big deal if it makes people happy it's
not bothering you then you know why be a
dick about it masculinity can be so
fragile you know what I mean and it just
sucks because it limits you so much if
you're so stuck in it that something as
simple as changing your last name
it's like this horrible thing that takes
away your manhood then like I mean that
just sucks for you of what matters is
that you love this person and you know
that's it that's all that matters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you